[Music]
a toddler slipped through a fence passed
heavily armed gents but will Biden's
security change after a child wandered
into sniffing range
[Music]
you guys on Tuesday a toddler squeezed
through a White House security fence and
actually got onto the grounds near the
north side of the building which means
we almost had two people speaking
gibberish in the Oval Office
[Applause]
Jimmy apparently the White House has
spent 64 million dollars since 2019 to
upgrade the fence although I'm guessing
most of that money actually went to
Ukraine too
anyway the child was unharmed and the
White House safely returned the boy to
her parents
[Laughter]
I wonder what old Joe's got to say about
this
no no no look that fence is like that on
purpose man
I like the kids
for so many reasons all right
but I'm not a sicko like that Dalai Lama
sticking out his tongue I come in from
behind all right I go in for the nape of
the neck I'm a nape smeller
good fella
and uh you know it's just kids and
ladies I like to smell it so but I can't
do it in public anymore I get in trouble
I need a private place
I need a sniff skiff
[Applause]
best-selling author Cat Tim our babies
the new Chinese spy balloon
they might be the security breach is
disgusting no I don't know but it is
what if I was being serious though I was
like you should be impeached for this uh
I think that I might be ready to be a
mother because if you can just lose your
baby in front of the president and get
to keep it then I'm going to be totally
fine
amazing
what have I been so worried about all
these years you I like I thought you had
to you know actually always you don't
have to keep track of it there's that
I'm getting pregnant tomorrow
you can do things uh Joey do you said in
the green room they should have
waterboarded the baby to make an example
why yes
um I think it's because I confuse
waterboarding with motor boating
it's Administration is made for some
awkward First Dates
um I don't did they get competitive
bidding for this project of this fence
like because if there's one thing
America knows how to do it's build a
fence that keeps unauthorized people for
entering secure areas that what was
what's their slogan like almost strong
enough to keep out a baby
kid but
current through the fence like a little
electricity
or something I mean the kid got close he
sensed there's diapers in there and he
made his move I don't I don't fault him
I don't fault him he's a go-getter that
kid I respect it
Chadwick has this baby inadvertently
revealed the way for Joe and Jill to
finally hang out with Hunter stripper
baby
well to be fair I think the fence was
built to keep Joe in if he was having a
bad day traffic
they spent 64 million dollars on this
fence and you can't have a way when
tourists visit to get a picture of the
White House without the fence in the way
I don't know if you've noticed that mid
to DC like millions of people come see
this house and you have a yes picture
this stupid right 64 million dollars yep
it's bananas it's bananas yeah I don't
know what to make of it but I will say
this because in the Green Room you said
it was nice to see someone on their
hands and knees in the white house
besides Monica Lewinsky
um took the words out of my mouth they
get frisky on the business Channel yeah
I'm kidding the Blue Dress no but no
Good callback but is it not so insane
because you go to bed at night you want
to believe at least at the White House
we're playing a little defense clearly
we're not were we naive this whole time
like meeting in previous generations or
do you think this is new
many times not many several times before
times they decided to make the fence
taller instead of wider and a little bit
wider I should say so the baby was able
to get in but I think I really think
this toddler would just wanted his own
press conference I think he just did
because it was last week the president
was in Ireland and he did give a press
conference to kids he did and now the
babies want one too so they said we're
just gonna go in and get it well I was
the parents said he just wanted to speak
to the guy in charge of the White House
but Xi Jinping couldn't come
oh
just let's have this talk Joey D
collectively have you ever felt like we
were living in a bigger laughing stock
of a country than right now no I mean
the only good news is that with Trends
continuing kids will be too fat to fit
through between
a cage it's
a weird uh Elian Gonzalez Vibe right you
look at that picture that I guess the
children are easier for our security
people to bring down now than the feisty
Cuban back in the day but yeah I mean we
were invaded by balloons and toddlers I
I don't know I don't know what how we
could be making it easier for people to
to penetrate the perimeter they
literally told us when Biden got elected
the adults were back in the room I'm
like yes and there's toddlers crawling
in with them I mean we've got balloons
and toddlers the only thing I can think
is there's going to be a security issue
next with cake cake or ice cream causing
a problem I just love your fat kid joke
I think that's really funny
the fat kids are actually that's a
safety mechanism you can't kidnap them
anymore because it takes too long you
know what I mean throw your back out
yeah you imagine being a kidnapper in
2023 you're like kid get in the van I
got candy the kid's like does it contain
peanuts
foreign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else